oui denise un premier candidat tout de
suite
écoutez moi je ne suis pas là j'épouse à
qui et pour quoi vous répondre
même à placer pour l'impôt d'automatique
y va le faire alors des comptes
resteront il est ce votre message une
fois qu'ils mangent et anthony l'étape
sonore et vous avez l'air sur votre
numéro de téléphone
il émule arrivé de vous appeler tout de
suite vous remercierez votre pays verlan
franchement ça c'est encore encore darty
berne
parce qu'en plus de ça vous avez les
moyens d'avoir un répondeur automatique
un répondeur automatique mais comme ces
problèmes cour suprême des mages pose
mes papiers quand même oui on a déjà des
cas tout à fait normal on est avec vous
tous mal à vous et vous allez associés
la carte que vous voulez la non mais
franchement j'aimerais savoir si je peux
prendre la carte que j'attendais non
c'est balèze ou pas c'est pareil sur
deux domaines
franchement écouter garcimore non vous
en profiter parce que pierre n'est pas
là aujourd'hui c'est surtout des félins
c'est la catégorie sera peut-être
différent voici la quatrième boulet non
mais parce que d'abord écouté
franchement et je les ai vus tout tout
les mêmes alors pourquoi semble plus
pareil je sais que vous voulez une
preuve respect de l'art quarter of the
soul pop et maintenant vous savez a
signé à quatre voyez vous le savez le
caio gobbo si l'on regarde tous parce
qu'il ya toute une équipe la dame alors
le plateau alors ils sont tous là avec
des airs de conte ici pas dans le coup
et montrer la chine y est signée c'est
plus je signe ou de rendre votre
signature
bon signe et bien écoutez c'est triste
comme nom moi montre la carte avec la
signature
oui oui c'est bien mais coûte maintenant
je vais me donner la parole à la main
droite
non la main droite mamadou sarr et vous
mettez la main comme ça tout acquis ce
n'est qu'à la maman qui avait soufflé la
carte il va pousser de la ici
mais j'admire la carte c'était du tf
n'est pas car vous savez ceux ci donc
c'était des tarots dur et je vois pas
pourquoi je vous mettrai sur l'avant
alors vous avez un vrai examen
nous verrons la main non mais c'est pas
facile et la main oui parce qu'il est
pas là il a disparu il ya quatre ans
avait signé des disparus porto fait
ouvrir les portes aux films attendus
avant nous un portefeuille je voudrais
que la caméra se rapproche maintenant
par simone enfants ça vaut la peine
non regardez le portefeuille non
regardez le portefeuille non mais
vraiment gênant location voilà alors
maintenant il faut que je prenne un
portefeuille alors jetez pas du tout si
le on va partiront pour le monde tout à
l'heure - n'aura pas le temps de faire
jouer qui que ce soit parce que avec
toutes les histoires de portefeuille et
de et le plus vite et que tech parce que
je peux quand même une mineure ben là je
vais vous dire c'est bien réciproque un
non mais ne riez pas pu trouver un autre
système quand même c'est pas si gentil
déjà 4 élastique qui sait pas tout
autant dépend non a coûté la vie ce qui
m'a fait regarder et là ça va tâcher de
nature c'est pas possible
non mais laissez moi non mais c'est pas
non mais franchement comment nom même
est comment vous avez fait non
moi je veux montrer à la regarder lancer
là dedans alors je vous garantis sans
aucune censure parole c'est regarder
impossible d'ouvrir moi je comprends
plus rien toute façon ça ne change pas
parce que nous partons pour le monde
directement non normal qu'un jouet de
fer avec un juge ou à des choses plus
faciles en fin de mois ou concerne parce
qu'au moins là j'ai les réponses tout à
cela je n'ai jamais la réponse de toute
façon ça il faut bien se le dire merci
garcimore
[Musique]